hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan
and h foley oh my word
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
the show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find out if they
grow up classy
or if they're a big old piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day here the fall has begun
here in new york city
the summer is over the perfect time to
do the garage fridge
contest we're here in the big studio
feeling good feeling fresh my co-host
coming at you right next to me he's got
a macbook pro
air in front of them well you might
still need a couple
payments nine this thing was paid in
cash by my wife okay
shout out to the weakling at nyu who
couldn't carry his book bag because i'm
a [ __ ] gentleman
how about that you know gang the next
time you're reaching for a best pal do
yourself a favor
make it a kippy this kid tastes great
he's less filling and
he's going to be on the cover of rogaine
magazine this week
articles and titles hanging in there
guys you catch him this weekend
this month in hair follicle quarterly
he's on forbes 30 under three inches
give it up for kevin ryan everybody hey
what's up gang
um just uh thanks for tuning in we
appreciate it so much
we do we have another host episode for
you where we're gonna go over to garage
fridges
the big contest baby the big giveaway of
you dirt balls and by the way
some of you need to [ __ ] call a
cleaning service
cause you stink okay i'm coming out and
saying it
i'm gonna start sending out [ __ ]
devry pamphlets
[ __ ] pick it up a little bit get a
second job do something let's go
we need high income demographic here
folks
we ain't going to make it selling the
low level [ __ ] we got to start moving
[ __ ] bmws [ __ ] johnny walker red i
don't know
um yeah guys thanks so much for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes get us back
in that top two hundo tell a [ __ ]
friend grab your wife's phone your
boyfriend's phone
your partner's phone latinx whatever you
need whatever you got cooking
nothing wrong with any of it just uh
just leave a review we appreciate it
um and also uh full video available on
youtube you can subscribe there as well
those numbers are
through the [ __ ] roof over 5 000
subscribers on youtube we appreciate
that you guys are the [ __ ] best
oh yeah um and uh also quick two quick
shout outs that uh
to to you guys um you're doing shout
outs now
nah it's for the show guys taking care
now it's for the show um
so there's uh there's a very rabid fan
base there's these guys started a reddit
are you familiar with reddit i'm
familiar with you you can check out the
ru gardens i've
read it before all right dylan cut that
why is it only on him by the way i gotta
look at kippy's face when i'm doing the
intro
yeah is this jumping back and forth yeah
what's going on here sweetie yeah
yeah was that the shot the whole time
no i was switching it around all right i
don't know it's cool
suspect back there i'm gonna have to get
bobby hutch in here we've been holding a
really good relationship with dylan
despite the criticism that comes from
outside sources
um yeah guys i got to put the moneymaker
up there kid the face is selling the pod
not cue ball over here i'll tell you
that
shut up i'm doing [ __ ] business okay
you're worried about the only thing you
got is your hairline all right tubsy
why don't we get let's get it let's get
a shot under the table for him
i look like i'm laying down look at look
see that's the problem you can
the back love handles are really getting
out of control yeah that's what that's
that's your problem the back love
handles
i'm that fact i'm always leaning nah
yeah it's called gravity tubsy um
guys uh if you're if you're a redditor
or whatever they're called you can check
out the
uh and subscribe to the subreddit uh
it's are you garbage and then also shout
out to steven mcquillen
on the facebook group there's a whole
facebook group guys we love you man
thank you everybody's posting pics
sharing stuff
laughing it's a [ __ ] family i love it
thank you so much everybody
we [ __ ] appreciate it i have to get
in there on one of my burner accounts
just a fat lady named trish
somebody made somebody made female
versions of me and took i thought you
did that
no so the facebook group did that and
they made female versions of me and
foley and dude you look like a trish
the last one of me with my with my old
headshot that's really good
pretty cute dude take a [ __ ] run at
it dude if it was 2007
and kippy had about 13 bud lights in
really a couple of fireball shooters
good night i'd be [ __ ] i'd be sending
you some pina coladas at the end on a
gift card
that i'm running a tab on hey bartender
do me a favor did you send down a tray
of mozzarella sticks for that cutie down
at the end of the day
just sending food yeah
put that margarita to draw for nobody
does that everybody says drinks
you want to get a girl in the rocks
instead of thinking of pot stickers
you want to get me in the sack you sent
down the [ __ ] sampler you know what
i'm talking about
oh dude you sent me listen the
gentleman's move
if you're out with a couple of buddies
by far is getting the [ __ ] sampler
because you always have the weirdo that
wants you know like oh let me get the
deviled eggs or something
it's like dude you get two of them and
stay off my [ __ ] moth sticks i'll
tell you that i'll tell you what the
denny sampler is
second to none i don't know what they
coat them fingers with
but you crack a tooth on them they're
crispy yeah i don't [ __ ] with that
speaking of great appetizers real quick
because you were talking about a version
of this but my cousin jordan got married
this weekend
congratulations to him and his beautiful
wife fantastic beautiful wedding
is that what you're giving him a shout
out instead of a present
you [ __ ] piece of garbage listen i'm
a little tight on funds hey this puts us
even by the way i'm still waiting on
that gas digital check to drop how about
a shout out on this tuesday show
no but they had that bill cheesesteak
dumplings
let me tell you that's but that's how
trashy philly is they just cheese steak
everything whatever
is so good from anything from the far
east they empty out and put some [ __ ]
steak gums in
cheese steak egg rolls cheesesteak pot
sticks cheesesteak covent that's not
that bad little ketchup
yeah ma'am i'm big dude put meat and
cheese in anything and sign me the [ __ ]
up daddy oh yeah
hey speaking of meat and cheese real
quick wanna give another special shout
out
i don't like this there's too many shout
outs let's start over
take it from the top well we got our
friend steve torielli
we're selling out who you know shout out
to the good folks at gm motors everybody
all our friends at halliburton everybody
[Laughter]
spring steve torielli who does amazing
gifts and all that stuff for
for for a lot of podcasts on uh on
twitter and instagram
tori ellie picks you guys should follow
them uh made up these uh these mug fours
for the mick foley yeah look at that
right there [ __ ] beautiful
we're gonna always have them on the desk
here drink our beverage out of uh
i'm not i'll stay out of my poland
spring bottle thank you very much that i
paid for by the way
all right waiting on that venmo yeah
let's get into it fully fully went out
to dinner for uh
for his girlfriend's uh yeah we need to
do another pre-sale
broke fully went out to a fancy dinner
with the first girlfriend
and while he's at dinner he's [ __ ]
texting me asking for the hundo that i
owe him
he's going yo can you venmo he goes that
this dude's got the balls to go to nobu
which it's like
[ __ ] 200 two bills a plate at nobu
he's got the balls to go to nobu in
shorts and he's
out and he texts me hey are we all
squared up what's up with that honda
like and i'm like
well i'm like yeah i'll send it to you
he's like yeah can you send it now i'm
like what's going on he's like i'm at
nobody i'm like
oh somebody got a little too big for his
[ __ ] waistband
somebody ordered two appetizers i told
her to keep it to one and we'd split it
she's out there [ __ ] throwing money
around like i'm [ __ ] roosevelt
dumping glass in there by the way can we
make it a little hotter in here i'm
[ __ ] schvitzen we're talking about
cash i'm [ __ ] sweating
yeah wait till the irs starts poking
around
god um yeah long gone by then what's
that
which that that uh that that brings it
up the the segway uh so we're gonna so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna get
to the garage fridge guys the
submissions from the garage bridges have
been [ __ ]
awesome some of you are yo hands down
clean [ __ ] living some of you got a
little bitty cage
you put the ryan's the shame on doing
well some of you're doing very well some
of you need to [ __ ] move back home
some of you need to throw away some food
yeah dude some of you
the one guy's just he just sent a
picture and it's just trash he has
actual
garbage and he goes yeah i use it as my
trash can
it's just proper fridge but i do that as
well because that's that's a better way
to go
now it's it's the better way to go
because you're going to take it out the
next day why keep it in the trash
when it's all where it's all stinky but
then take it out that night that's
garbage i'm not taking the trash out
that night and going to the alley where
the rats are at night what are you
nuts i only do that during the day and i
throw it from right
from never you shot putting a back shot
putting a hefty bag
you fat piece of [ __ ] um well how's that
supposed to make me feel
trying over here i got new shirts by the
way i'm done with the george collection
i'm sure the weight's going to start
falling off now guys he's got new
t-shirts everything's all right
uh i'm a dxl man now all the way
um guys we appreciate uh everybody if i
can send it in the video somebody went
as far to like upload it to youtube they
put a little music behind it
good narration some of you [ __ ] home
runs we really appreciate it production
quality
um and also uh we're so
in the first half of the question we're
going to just stick with the first half
of the app we're going to dick around
you know
do a little kippy foley we're doing it
now we got some listener questions and
this is one of the first listener
listeners questions really that we were
talking about weddings
and this is i know we'll we have this
will be a sticking point we've had this
conversation before but it is
real trash at the wedding no this is
from
aaron is it garbagio to get a hotel room
at a hotel close by the designated
wedding
yeah good luck getting the [ __ ]
bridesmaid back there you [ __ ] dirt
ball
the last stop on the shuttle then you
gotta take a [ __ ] taxi
wait hold on let me get through the
questions
ah it's just a quick uber ride 45
minutes down the road this is a home run
of a question
is it a garbage to get a hotel room at a
hotel close by the designated wedding
hotel
to save a couple of boxes that is
trash yeah that's trash garbage is fun
garbage is cute that's just [ __ ] well
like
so some of you might not go to classy
weddings i don't know but a lot of
so just so everybody's familiar you get
a hotel you get a wedding invitation
it'll say hey accommodations you know
you just say the foley
ryan i'm here for the fully ryan wedding
all right uh
he's going okay you get like a
discounted rate and the discounted rate
stinks it's typically you save like 20
bucks or something like what are we
doing
um but they off they typically offer two
hotels if you're a classy guy you'll do
two hotels hey we're at the w
and we're at the [ __ ] no you don't do
that nah you do that cause like do some
i just did it right before covet hit the
beginning of march we went it was like
the marriott was the one and the other
was the lows you didn't even have a real
wedding that doesn't count that's just
not my wedding
oh sweating who got married
it was very nice down in philly at the
lowe's hotel ooh
but the marriott's right at the movie
theater the mario throw it across the
street if you know what i mean
sit in a marriott in providence not too
long ago
good oh great story you should do i
can't
can i get my can i get a host in here
good hot dogs up in rhode island
probably making them in the room
foley brings a roller no no no i'll
carry himself i'll don't touch my bangs
do you put the privacy can you send an
extension cord out to
room 102 you're on the first floor
if you guys have any gloves that'd be
good you said a pair of tongs up
some relish station maybe oh do you do
that i do do you do the no problem you
put the privacy thing on when you check
in
i don't want them coming in and cleaning
uh it depends how long i'm there for
if i'm on the road yeah if i'm like
what's the longest you've been in a
hotel
like four nights or whatever like
recently or like a video on the road if
i go away just [ __ ] do
road work you're there for like three or
four nights um
so yeah i don't want people in my room
especially because i'm not doing much
i don't want to rooting around my
[ __ ] five five five dominoes deal
either i don't want them throwing that
[ __ ] out
leave that sit for a couple days you
know what i mean daddy oh that bacon
only gets better with age
no uh but what i do like to do if it's a
wedding and everybody's going for the
weekend the weekends are fun you go in
the night before if you're in the party
or whatever
if you're going for the night you get
the hotel room listen of course so if
you're on for a weekend which i unless
you're close
because i didn't get i didn't get the
room for my cousin's wedding because
yeah you're spending it at nobu
i didn't owe you any more money maybe 45
minutes down the road
yeah take the old man home yeah yeah
can't stay overnight anymore
um know what i'm saying which is fun is
uh you do the uh
you want a couple of buddies at the
airbnb so you have the party house
because otherwise if you're there for
two or three nights
the airbnb is nice okay
if that's what you want to do now do you
want to know what class does what
gentleman's do
not give a gift at the wedding and drive
home that night who said i didn't give a
gift at the wedding
by the way let's get into it what did
you give
can you is that isn't it crass to say
that publicly if you're embarrassed by
it sure
depends what you get yeah uh i did two
bills
cash in an envelope it's not bad it's
good it's average
20s oh i had that you gave [ __ ] eight
twenties and twenties i figure if you
gotta break somebody off
what yeah you gotta grease somebody yeah
go hundos
twenties you might as well put a roll of
quarters in there
[Laughter]
give them the coin star receipt what's
the most you ever gave close family
you know i bet you're not even over 175
no i'll do
walking around in your h m suit i think
i don't know i'd have to ask he's
listening to this
if you wrote it down nick text me and
told tell me probably two to three bills
three bills huh two to three bills doing
pretty good i think if it's you if it's
you on the left i'm going with me and
the lady
of course you do one i think i did 150
150 probably
150 yeah weird number 150 go evens
oh do you [ __ ] 1920 you probably
shorted that at 22.
[Laughter]
you put one he put one less 20 in there
to try to get away with it
he opened up the card on the way there
you probably take two envelopes with you
don't you
you get see how the crab cakes are take
one
out yeah um yes that is [ __ ] garbage
to answer your question well you see
it's nice to stay at the
at the hotel where everybody is that way
when you come back
from the wedding you all get boozed up
in the lobby of the hotel and then you
just go
right upstairs yeah you go to bed then
you're up fresh in the morning you get
up early in the morning
you take a nice shower and you get down
there for the [ __ ] brunch
i agree but the hotel bar tends to close
a little early they're not [ __ ] 2 3
4 a.m well that's why if you got a
[ __ ] spot around the corner a little
little smoky smokey little party got the
tunes going
that's what you do okay okay you
had a solution for that and we did the
same thing at my brother's wedding
when the bar's closing down you just ran
out before paying the bill no you
just say give me uh give me 12 heinekens
before they close it out
you're drinking heinekens at a wedding
why not oh it was the only two
thousand it's all it's on the cuff puffy
was drinking him back then what do you
mean we didn't know any better
yeah um no i always go liquor at a
wedding
i'm a big cocktail guy these days
believe it or not i'm kind of done with
the beers
like a nice like nice margarita nobu
made a real nice one
yeah 45 yeah somebody said all class
kippy that's what i liked
when he said nose beers too don't know
what you're talking about
um i got one you um you
this is a this is a me personal one that
was i didn't think it was trashy until
it was phrased this way
so i was going home this weekend i was
talking to a buddy he's like oh you know
what
what are you doing i said going down to
uh my family's my mom's house right
she's away for the weekend so i got the
house and the burbs to myself where's
she slutting around
this weekend she listened shout out
denise
um where was she they were down the
shore so i got a course i got the i got
the house to myself
and the burbs nice green grass deer
coming up while you're out there smoking
ciggies drinking beers doing it nice
my only problem with you posting the
videos of your back you don't have a
pool
you have a pool that's above ground yeah
and i think it's in you i think it's in
your driveway
i've never seen it during the winter
i'll tell you that much do you take it
down
i've been to foley's house i've never
seen the pool so you tell me it's like a
carnival one time
not a neighbor's got it moved two towns
over
it'll be back um what
but so my my stepdad's dad
right my stepdad's dad right passed away
okay but he had a house with a pool
and now we're talking we still my you
know that that
you stole the pool stuff and sold it no
that house is still in the family but no
one lives there
oh here we go so i go over we use the
pool it's like [ __ ] you know
it's taking care of the pool it's club
ryan over there the kids are guys we
just like
we use it like it's our pool and then my
buddy goes wait let me get this straight
you're driving two hours down to use a
dead guy's pool
and i said oh you phrase it that way it
is pretty [ __ ] trashy
who's taking care of it they pay
somebody uh yeah somebody like somebody
family friend comes and skims and does
whatever he's not still in the house is
he
you guys report it to death i hope you
just turn the air conditioner down a
little bit
keep on keep the social security check
is coming keep them on ice
um no yeah and then i guess yeah i'm
like oh yeah we're just using a dead
guy's pool it's pretty trashy when you
look at that why don't you make an offer
on that house that way you can have a
you can have a summer place
offer on the house make it a family
discount
plus a bereavement's fee
nah he can stay he can stay um
yeah i don't know i felt real trashy
once it was i go yeah i guess we're just
now everybody in the family using it
cousins like dude sometimes you guys
go inside yeah if you have to go the
bathroom or whatever
oh that's [ __ ] garbage i know i know
i know is there a pool house
no but sometimes you go and there's
people there that you don't know and i'm
like all right
just like it is dude everybody that
everybody that's ever known this guy is
just using the pool i don't know if
that's legal if you can have a pool
if no one's occupying the house is there
a fence around the pool
you said you [ __ ] johnny zone wall
what are you doing what does that even
mean
what are you talking it's illegal to
well you can't have in pennsylvania you
can't have a pool unless you have a
fence around
what's that say about anybody living in
a house because there's no one there to
watch it
do you have a fence or not who's
watching your pool right now there's
people there
do you have a fence around yes you have
to is there a lock on it yes
do you know the coat yeah i just jump it
though
do you yeah oh my jumping fence days are
over
you got a better job whatever there was
jumping fence days for you yeah what do
you mean i top offense
climb it up jump it over not now though
now i'm a nobo yeah okay
um what this is another one we got
[Music]
this have you ever packed clothes in a
trash bag instead of a suitcase
and that's from chad you asking me yeah
yes yeah it's tough this is the first
apartment that i've had where
i've been like a human being like with
me and my girl like you know like
furniture and [ __ ] like that
especially up here when we moved up here
i was [ __ ]
you know i had no nothing eating tuna
every night
that's all i had was a trash bag i was
in a trash bag
you know when i moved from uh astoria to
bushwick
our buddy siobhan moved this that was
all trash bags
yeah always if you had to move right now
what are you moving it because i'm
moving this week
if i if i had them we're talking about
it all right because we want to
maybe get a two bedroom or take
advantage of the uh the
the downturn in real estate in new york
that's what we did
if you need a cosigner let the kid know
uncle hank might be on the upper upper
east side by tuesday
uh if i move again with the amount of
things i'm definitely getting
a mover i'm not do i'm not doing that
anymore no way
movers all the way um but still what do
you put
what are you putting the clothes in
boxes yeah putting the clothes in boxes
or [ __ ] bags
you got box money this guy's got [ __ ]
boxes we got box money
um because we're getting ready to move
this week and we're talking
i'm out of town i don't need i don't
need you [ __ ] having a heart attack
on the second that's another thing i'm
not helping anybody move anymore either
forget about it
dylan um i think
because my wife is like oh yeah for the
clothes we'll just use trash bags i'm
like
we're moving into a nice building in a
nice neighborhood i'm going i need to
walk
my first impression ain't being carrying
[ __ ] listen she's
called kitchen bags with cold with
[ __ ] my jeans in them
scented ones everything smells like
vanilla when i get upstairs
listen she's a good kid she's new in
town don't [ __ ] embarrass us up there
all right
that's what i said i said no [ __ ] way
are we doing that they're saying hizzle
off or dusseldorf
i'll put all of my clothes on and walk
into the house
steal a hotel cart
is the pool open by any chance um yeah
that's a tough one i had a girl um i
know a girl who
goes to shows flaming lips
called uh tangerine i believe yeah
uh she don't use jelly's name song
anyway that's neither here nor there
um but i had a girl break up with me
one time and i knew it was i knew it was
serious because
she put all my clothes in trash bags and
they were waiting for me when i got
there sweet free bags
you done broad thanks honey got this bro
coming and going huh
everything comes up fully got some
i got i got four free full free hefty
bags
uh she folded everything and put them in
the trash bag so that's why i knew it
was it was serious
because she took a lot of thought folded
them up
yeah never had that that's like a
[ __ ] rem video
have you ever rem i don't know have you
think of some [ __ ]
[ __ ] bag band that you used to listen to
in the 90s i'm surprised you knew the
flaming lips
you're a kanye guy you're a hip-hop guy
who do you like takashi
213 what's his name yeah that's who i
like um have you ever been broken up
have you ever been dumped no no never
been in a real relationship
before this i used to make my living
getting dumped so i didn't know it
doesn't take and dumb
i oh yeah i've never been the breaker up
the breaker up e i've always been the
yeah you can't do it no um all right
let's do one one two more and then we'll
hop into the big
contest this is big what's at stake here
free t-shirt two free tease
two wait a minute wait a minute
we'll do we'll do you get one garbagio
and one free clean living if you already
have bought one
we'll give you the opposite color or
whatever you want yeah whatever you want
so if you bought a white garbagio
we'll give you a black garbagio and a
clean living of your choice
okay if you if it's more than an xl you
have to pay extra
you have to be able to juice it by the
way we got to work on some big boy sizes
for the next pre-sale dell
yeah no that dude wanted a 6x bro we
don't that's nuts
why is that not [ __ ] custom what do
you use yeah that's a petite smaller
itself shirts if he wants and a [ __ ]
pair of scissors yeah we got to get the
iron-ons going that was my that was my
brain
that was my genius idea what start doing
iron-ons that way you could they could
put them on whatever clothing that fits
them
yeah but it's buying it's like fi it's
buying a 6x shirt that's not how
business works
business what do you mean i listen fatso
i don't have
i don't have the [ __ ] time to expect
there's that much difference that's
that much difference in overhead cost
between a three x and a six well if
you're buying 500 [ __ ] large shirts
how many fat listeners do we have no
when they buy the shirts for the show
they buy 500 at a time instead of going
to buy one
6xl and people really don't probably
stock 6xl
when was the last time you were in
pennies and caught a 6xl catching the
clearance rack every once in a while
right
somebody that bought it online and then
returned it all right let's do one more
here let's make it a
goodie i love the wedding one that's
great that was dude he hit
i got that like two weeks ago and i was
like i gotta [ __ ] save this one yeah
you stay at the hotel down the street
then
because otherwise uh how you getting
back because a lot of times they do like
the shuttle from the one place to the
other everybody's hopping in and you
you gotta get to the bus station you
gotta take a greyhound you run me to the
hour johnson's real quick
anybody going down towards the river or
whatever let me tell you something those
shuttle drivers at weddings are usually
[ __ ] pricks
they don't want to do anything yeah well
they're working on a saturday night with
a bunch of drunk [ __ ]
i take an uber i don't need to be
dependent upon anybody an uber well a
lot of times they're like
oh yeah the shuttle's coming back and
it's like well there's only one shuttle
and it's gotta go it's like it takes
[ __ ] 10 hours to get back
meanwhile you smoked 500 cigs the bars
closed [ __ ]
mum's the word i'm like hey i'm getting
the [ __ ] out get it get to get the
last chopper get out
some drunk ant on there busting balls
all right this is uh let's do this one
is from suki
the suki have you ever brought a bag of
loose beers to a party or gathering
loose beers just like you know whatever
you grab a couple out of the fridge and
like we're you know
you're not walking in with a package
six-pack 12-pack
you're coming in with like two white
claws a [ __ ] ipa
well let me two mountain dews let me all
right now you're talking my language
couple of code reds [ __ ] spark the
party up now here's the thing
are they artisanal beers like you know
an ipa
that's different but also you're buying
a six pack of it unless you're like a
beer snob where i wouldn't understand
what kind of beer it is
and it's got those in the cans with the
crazy labels
unless you're bringing those loose
that's artisanal but if you're rolling
up with like
a [ __ ] bud heavy two course lights or
[ __ ] schlitz
you got a [ __ ] problem half a
sandwich yeah yeah that's trash i had a
re this summer somebody had came over to
my parents to go swimming
um uh a relative by marriage
okay now you know how we do it would you
charge them
uh you know how we do it and we you know
we pride ourselves on
you know don't bring anything you don't
need nothing and [ __ ] that's throwing
our [ __ ]
i'm good for something i swear to god i
might suck in life but i'll give you
meatballs
but he showed up with his own little
little cooler of beers miller lights
cans wait he showed up with a cooler a
little
like a little mini like like well this
is a problem if you're bringing your
bring for everybody you don't bring it
for yourself br
if you show up to somewhere bring it for
yourself when they say hey we got plenty
of stuff
and you only bring beer for yourself
that's
trashy you should bring at least a 12
pack to be like hey i'll leave
i'll drink six and if nobody else wants
them i'm leaving them for you guys for
whatever he kept them
in those little cuz little cooler and
like when he got there and sat down or
whatever you know obviously you go
around hey can what can i get you guys
to drink
can i get you something that you said
i'm drinking it's like nah i got uh i
got some beers in the
in the cooler and i'm like what i mean
he's like yeah
i brought a few beers i'm like we got
[ __ ] a whole fridge
of [ __ ] ice cold [ __ ] bottles of
beer
and he just drank he just drank his
that's weird that's a garbage move
yeah yeah you can't bring a [ __ ] head
stash unless it's like
unless it's like a [ __ ] bite you know
it's a late night thing and you're like
i'll bring up
just kind of everybody bring what you
got like bring for yourself type thing
that stuff gives me major social anxiety
what just like those situations like
that like i could never be that guy
that brings something just for himself
i'd have to you know everything you know
well if i call and i'm like hey do you
guys need beer and they're like no just
you know what i mean like we're good
here just bring for whatever you have
then i would grab a six or twelve like
sure but like if i was going over
someone's house for a hang
mm-hmm and i said hey do you need to be
like no we're good and i'm like why
i still want to bring my [ __ ] six
beers for myself you bring more than the
six beers for yourself
as a gesture it's like a bottle of wine
given they don't want the six beers it's
the you know
that's like i don't like a potluck you
know what a pot look yeah i don't [ __ ]
with dude i would never do a [ __ ]
potluck in my life give me a waiter i
don't want to go to your house i need
some bad [ __ ]
marshmallow yams or some [ __ ] give me a
waiter with a special
and a [ __ ] appetizer and i hit the yo
ambrosia hit the bricks with that [ __ ] i
love it
this is then we'll get this will be i
don't know if i've ever told you a story
we went away i mean like 10 friends we
rented a mountain house
years ago and it was like the
you know everybody brings the food
everybody throw up a hundred bucks or
whatever 50 covers the house for
everybody and then
right the other 50 you know half of it
goes to beer half goes to the food we
just hang at the house you go to the
grocery store when you get there
no i think people brought it up we were
like you know someone went shopping was
like hey it was 200 and i'm like oh
we'll go get
300 worth of beer whatever it is you
know everybody puts up 100 bucks
chop it up go home you know whatever so
we were staying for three nights and
uh someone could only someone could only
stay for uh
two nights so they were leaving before
the last night you know
okay so we're sitting there grilling and
everything and uh
everybody had the people that are
leaving leave and this this girl leaves
and she leaves
and then we grilled right and we like
sat down for dinner this
girl had already left took the buns with
her took the ketchup
what she took the ketchup home with her
because she bought the ketchup
so now you've got like 10 people who are
having a barbecue with no ketchup
and we're in the middle of the [ __ ]
woods and we're like we're sitting there
like dude there was a four gallon thing
of ketchup here you know what i mean
[Laughter]
that got me i gotta give you that look
at him i'm like where the [ __ ] this
broadcame
took the ketchup home with her dude
we were like who is like i need this six
dollars or
because it was a big one or whatever but
still taking it home
leaf dude you're leaving 10 people at a
cabin high and dry
for the best we sit down for a barbecue
with no [ __ ] fun sauce
that's real shifty i went to uh i went
to
a friend's country club for dinner
all right this was years ago now i don't
know if you know how country clubs work
you're a [ __ ]
bozo from [ __ ] bucks but my family
belongs to country clubs
private yeah what's the name of it
manufacturers
guest pass i think you know the
gentleman
i believe another gentleman from bucks
county um okay so you know that when you
when
you're a member of a country club you
got to spend a certain amount of cash
but yeah you got to so it's like a 2 000
restaurant minimum or something yeah
so me and my lady get the invite from
their parents
to go okay okay we gotta get through
this but yeah all right so me we get the
invite it's so it's uh it's
me and my girl him and his girl and his
parents
[ __ ] parents years ago okay years ago
i didn't know you then
i was a different guy okay wasn't always
a guy
he wasn't always a stand-up hey hey hey
production team he wasn't always this
[ __ ] stand-up stud we got going on
over here
he was a different guy okay don't blame
him on these actions alone
stole the silverware anywho the check
comes
now i've worked at [ __ ] country clubs
all my life
shout out to meadowlands country club no
longer there uh
i know how it works so i'm thinking i'm
[ __ ] crab cakes
not over ordering but i'm having a nice
meal you're not under order neither
i'm not having a [ __ ] appetizer for
my entree i'll take that yeah
the [ __ ] bill comes and the old man
[ __ ] says ah just give me 200. well
call it even i'm like you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah you're making
money off of me
yeah yeah cause he's got to spend it
regardless yeah
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] trash that's a
trash move if you got the money you jump
on the grenade even if you don't have it
i'd pay
i'd let my card get declined before i
had somebody for that oh absolutely yeah
um you know i don't like that split and
check [ __ ] yeah because you're a waiter
i got you
that's right uh i was a server okay it
was
things are going very well [ __ ] take
out burger joint i got you
um all right guys let's [ __ ] get into
it yes sir the reason we're all here
this is the time so dale i think we're
going to go
into it and then we're going to go we're
going to announce we're going to do the
build up right
yeah so whenever you guys want me i can
do the intro yeah do the intro
and then um and cut it to us and then
we'll get into the
the participants yes
very nice this is it baby
that's my mom's garage
her dildo falls out garage fridge
2020 contest starts right now
you gotta get a haircut it's a looker
put some product
in that
look at that spending all the graphic
money here look at
this guy huh
it baby pro tools dylan back there i
like it
um all right so this is how it's gonna
go we're gonna run through
some honorable mentions some
participants this could be either like
really trashy
or really good but just not good enough
you know what i mean these are kind of
little over the board and then we got
you know um then we're gonna announce
the winner as well so
uh dill and then me and foley have ours
when do you want to run ours
let's do ours first let's do ours first
i was about to say yeah let's go let's
open with your guys
cool cool awesome dude wants to go first
all right but
this was unstocked my mom's current
fridge
i did put the login in there that's mine
all right we'll roll with this so this
is fully
pause it real quick
[Music]
so that's my mom's garage okay that's a
heckinger's
uh i know that things about the that
rack's about to fall over by the way
all right so now as kevin was saying
this was this was
they weren't this is the end this is the
end of the summer all right the end of
the season deal go back to the
go back to the yeah so we can say it so
this is what's left there
all right what's that music
molly thought he was having a heart
attack you guys hear
angels guys i think i'm dead
you guys you guys smell me and if
somebody put me in a freezer
you guys smell burnt toast nobody's
swimming in my bowl nobody's swimming at
dead man's pool
swimming in a dead man's bed so this is
the end of the season go ahead
you can play it through it looks
admirable so we got some modules on the
left there for a couple of the family
members of your phone that have an issue
i was trying to do like some cool stuff
look we got uh bud lights we got uh mg
or uh miller genuine drafts we got
waters for the kids
okay and then we got those ice things oh
those wait pause it pause it pause it
pause it
back get up patio those ice things
what are they they're great they're
they're like 38 cents you get four
million of them i know
dude the first i found them in my mom's
garage fridge too the first time i ever
have one
suck that down with a cold dirt they're
sugar they're sugar free long boys
mango black raspberries that's a weird
flavor
that orange mango is [ __ ] clean
living patio
that thing is something else and i don't
know i don't know if they if they
couldn't afford like
full carbonation in them but they go
down real smooth oh yeah they got a
little
bite to them though too in a good way
all right that's an admirable fridge you
got your different beers the pull could
do you pull like a still shot of it at
just some point give me like a
give me a two shot well you didn't look
at the freezer yet
oh i didn't know go ahead go ahead and
play that and hey gang you can always
make sure if you listen to this go over
to youtube watch it on youtube or
sign up gas digital network dot com you
can watch it in hd use promo code a-y-g
or you can watch it in sd somebody just
said
oh no it's aaron just said why do moms
always have spriter 7
up those are airplane cans too they're
not full kitchens oh that's juicy i
don't got those on discounts i don't
know where
she got them [ __ ] things hanging out
at the airport again
down there in cargo city baby
so when the planes land you're in charge
now we got to get through these okay
milky way all right
all right dill show us his uh yeah okay
just let this play through them
yeah you got the ice he's got the fruit
drinks the ice cream look at us in the
corner right there that's [ __ ] nice
[ __ ] nice we got [ __ ] you got the
sodas
i don't see mine i don't see many diet
options in that fridge though i'll tell
you that
what are you having a stroke what the
camera crimpets
fresh bag of ice the big bag a little
bit of turkey turkey
okay somebody sprains an ankle i got a
[ __ ] ice pack ice pops
[ __ ] two things of butter yep and
then we got that so
trash dude all the paper thousands
what's that carpet would you [ __ ] rob
willy wonka
got the [ __ ] the the red and white
arrow carpet we got old rugs in there
keep the oil stopped that's not too
shabby that's an average fridge that's
nice that's an average that's end of the
summer okay
all right i'll give it to you it's end
of the summer um i forgot to take that
can of paint
all right dill run uh run mine please
this is my this is this is my mother's
fridge
and i have to say the only thing i did
put in there was uh
the the beer for me that's all i just
put in one sixer for me
and which i want to say is i realize is
trash is we leave everything in
that's [ __ ] we leave everything in
the box you know what i mean
first things first hit him with the boom
lag and eat his ipa because i'm a
[ __ ] gentleman
if you know what i mean solo lacroix
you know what i mean back there for my
european friend shout out
one peroni there's a couple of corrodes
what are those things pickled hot
sausages shout out to them what the [ __ ]
is that in the back
no he's got eyeballs in his fridge
sprites yeah but go back
kevin's got a thing of eyeballs what was
that
they're like pickled tomatoes oh what
are you what's this moe's tavern
pickled [ __ ] guy
they came with the house pickled
look at that herbs pickled hot sausage
holy [ __ ] they were there herbs when you
know you're trash
they were there when we moved in there's
a name like herbs it's got a
couple of rocky mountain oysters back
there
holy [ __ ] this guy's got whale nuts in
the fridge that's disgusting
and hold on what's with this
corona is left over from the shout out
you got your diet cokes like a gentleman
diet sprites for the lady who keeps milk
in the garage fridge
you got oat coca-cola screaming cold
case of white claws some capri suns for
the kitty that's [ __ ] one percent
too this guy ate one of them milk one
percent which is some [ __ ] [ __ ]
mom's about that rosenberg oh there you
go there's some points right there
pepsi's what is that easter got some
weird pickled sausages
some weird [ __ ] in the back not really
yeah single [ __ ]
easter candy you know who lives there
some random assortment offensive
coordinator but then this
talk about new [ __ ] money we got a
bottle
of dom perignon the garage for 3 000
in the [ __ ] garage bridge that is as
ricky bobby as you can [ __ ] get
are you even supposed to keep it cold or
is it supposed to be warm i think you're
supposed to
serve it chilled probably you don't keep
it chilled
yeah obviously they're getting ready to
celebrate something dude dad's been in
there since 2000 someone's about to get
the dust knocked off of him i'll tell
you that
the only way he's about to have a new
brother
[Laughter]
cutting in on the inheritance breaking
out the dom perignon that's too
funny dude those two weird meats and the
ones like tomatoes
i don't know what it is dude it's just
it's been in there since i can remember
yeah that's man pickled hot sausage
well i don't even know you dude nobody's
ever touched them i don't know where
they came from
i honestly don't the what we do know a
guy who owns like a meat store so i
think like
it came from there i guess i don't
[ __ ] know uh-huh
when was he over what
i don't know all right let's get into
some of the listeners to do
that was too funny what's that holy [ __ ]
that was really good
so these are the runner-ups these are
the runner-ups these are the you know uh
notable mentions let's say
great job on the graphics guys if you
step your game up next year you know you
might be in the you might be in
contention
all right let's take a peek what's up
uncle hank thank you hey big bry
doing my video for this great american
pastime called the beer fridge it's my
beer fridge start out with the freezer
side
got some omaha steaks like a gentleman a
little bit of mold to it
get the bleach god damn give that thing
a wipe down i might have weird food but
you got mold daddy
that's nasty plus is he got a little
wackaroo in him
sounds a little this guy looks like
you're shut up it's all high on mold
all right now we're getting that's a
fridge damn that's pretty good
let's just keep that still frame for a
second i see you got the coffee made on
the bottom which isn't too bad you can
put that out there
butter and coffee mate are the only
dairy products
that should be in the garage fridge all
right milk boys unless it's an overflow
overflow yeah you're using that much
milk where you got to put a half a
gallon in the freezer yeah she watches
the kids
all right i guess so i mean but you got
multiple beers in there you got the
coors lights you got a little bit
some nitro you got some good beers you
got some dosekis you got something else
in the blue
i can't tell but i would have some looks
like you got some strawberry yogurts
not dude the gatorade the 32 ounce
gatorade or whatever that is is a
[ __ ] home run pick
i don't know what they're two for three
a wawa i don't know what it is
gatorade must freeze at a lower
temperature
because i put a gatorade in the freezer
and i swear it's like 31 32 degrees
they are so [ __ ] yeah that's why i use
it in my car so huh
all right run it we're running out of
time here no we're not
here we are having a good time all right
we got your your seltzer's your
lifebeard section what's in those
sections some porch ruckers
some gatorades for the kids yeah coffee
mate for the man
borgia baileys
that's pretty good that's pretty good
man that's a runner-up
that's that's a runner-up that's a nice
garage yeah all right big b
on the board shut up that looks good
living life down there at the beach big
bry
all right all right that's [ __ ] nice
dude let's get into the next one dill
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
yo you thought i was weird wait a minute
you're gonna have a hard time finding a
classier individual
online also i did not add this music
this is all his production
you got children enjoyed this just enjoy
a couple bottles of an awesome wrong
as our buddies across the atlantic cut
to the girl you have tied up in the game
this guy's got creepo mode on him
[Music]
what are you got a bunch of wieners in
jars over there georgia peach
coca-cola where do you mean i'm looking
for a southern gentleman
canada dry aquafina's okay
aquafina not quite fiji
but not even close to fiji
fiji dude you couldn't even pick out
fiji on a map you got a mixer in there
uh and what this is a [ __ ] runner-up
come on got
natty lights for the 110
south carolina white hillbilly south
carolina though i'll give him that
i feel like he snuck into the neighbor's
garage
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's bad points as far as i'm
concerned no good
[Music]
you tried i'll give you that you tried
you got one or two nice things and you
got one or two you know honorable
mentions why did you open up with the
[ __ ] pickles or whatever the alien
bodies in there what the [ __ ] is that
yikes
stop memority stop making your own [ __ ]
okay
it ain't gonna get that bad stop by my
brother all summer [ __ ] making
pickles oh my god stop with it
wait they're making pickles they're
making pickles over there not bad i'll
tell you that
times must be done but stop that stop
making that pickles
that's trash um good job i mean hey
thanks for thanks for sending in
it was okay at best i'll give you an
okay it was a passing grade
we definitely saw worse that was a
passing grade though the production
quality was great i'll give you
got a couple of freeze frames a creepy
voice
but that would definitely be in the hbo
horror story
yeah tell your neighbors to get rid of
the pickles
who directed that josh whedon uh what's
going on somebody said what the [ __ ] is
this guy
uh all right let's see what we got
what is this now you still runner up
though uh five days old
uh this is like two three weeks old
ordered just last night
[ __ ] ton of beer that's about two weeks
old this is about two weeks old
that's good beetroot oh i love those
potatoes i'd love to pause it pause it
if i love those [ __ ] yeah those
simply shout out to
simply potatoes all right thank you hold
on take it every spring on foley's face
when he realizes those potatoes
they're great take it from the top again
please sorry
okay all right just hold it here pause
it first of all this is a mess you have
way too many takeout containers and you
didn't eat out
you didn't eat take out that many times
this week some of those are old
why do you have that what the [ __ ] how
many hot peppers he's got
this guy helping us hoagie shots this
guy puts my mom to shame jesus
christ dude
he's listening to the show though back
there that's pretty clever
two three weeks old what everything's up
last night [ __ ] ton of beer
two weeks old this is about two weeks
that's good meat too right there
dirty as [ __ ] we don't [ __ ] do our
own potatoes and some sort of weird oh
dude that was a science straight [ __ ]
garbagio i mean look
hot belly hot peppers a gallon of this
yeah tight looking kid
pan down on that can you see that body
is doing it shirtless that's the next
contest the old are you garbage wee-wee
contest
um yeah dude come on dude it's like
that's the
laziness there that's not even like
quality of brains you just got bad food
in there
the cans are all strong about come on
yeah that's not a garage fridge
yeah that's a [ __ ] that's a that's a
cry for help
but i like it he had some classy items
in there because i don't know there was
one thing okay meat the square meat
that's just the packaging
that you're getting fooled by that's
regular meat overpriced yeah that's
usually free range organic yeah whatever
that's fine though they sell it at
[ __ ] whole foods for six bucks
and he had a bottle of kombucha in there
which is pretty close yeah and also
15 things of old takeout that gets
defunct yeah anybody can come across
three bucks to get cam boots
so this is a good video to point out uh
a lot of mini fridges and just
dirty garbage regular fridges yes this
is where that falls into that category
this is just
nasty yeah all right uh
buddy throw out some stuff you know you
take good care of yourself take
care of your fridge you're a good
looking kid that's right don't want it
topless had a tight body on you
you're letting the [ __ ] fridge go to
waste come on
maybe that's why the good-looking guys
can get away with it i gotta keep my
fridge spotless
you just said you put trash in fair
enough
overnight take it out in the morning i'm
not an animal
all right what do we got though so here
we go
right guaranteed top level garbage
hundred percent look at this dude and i
mean come on bro
chocolate bars where the butter is
supposed to go who are you [ __ ] with
catnip this guy's missing peace come on
now
v8 juice that shit's been in there for
20 years
old ass ketchup we need to go food
shopping today i don't know what the
[ __ ] that
is what is with the disorganization of
you people there's [ __ ] down is up up
is down
we're looking for a [ __ ] nice garage
fridge you listen to the show
oh he's got breath mints in the [ __ ]
on the door of the fridge
if they're percocets that's classic i
keep my like my painkillers i like my
pk's on ice daddy oh keep the sheriff's
department guessing you know what i mean
the dog can't smell through the [ __ ]
kitchen ooh dude
this is nuts yeah some of you people are
anime nice beverages okay gatorades
[ __ ] ice in the fridge he's got
catnip in there dude what are you doing
what are you huffing you're keeping
catnip around i'll tell you what though
that spicy brown mustard that's laying
down there
ain't too shabby yeah i'll give you that
i believe why is it laying
down put it up what would you just have
an earthquake what's happening in there
oh man that was telling you it was the
rest of that yeah run that through from
the yeah just from there it's fine
jeez ketchup we need to go food shopping
today don't know what the [ __ ] that is
icebreakers even a block of provolone
come on now
stop it hey stop it ain't nobody [ __ ]
with us
come on now where's the kid top tier
trash
the kid that can't [ __ ] with the kid
they can't [ __ ] with him
come on cbd in the fridge
we got whatever the hell that is over
there
because she comes from the trailer park
we want her to remember her route to
where she came from
what's that warrant what's the fact shut
up stop that [ __ ] in there get out of
here
come on now oh my god come on now more
batteries what do you want to do
bro i'm trash this guy's got multiple
places for batteries in the fridge
i i'm against having batters in the
fridge it's a dirt ball move
but you got them at one in the produce
drawer the other and the crisper what's
happening well i want to know where do
they keep the meth
this couple is [ __ ] just dude they're
on uppers down or sideways these guys
are all over the [ __ ] place
which by the way dude you win
personality home run
oh yeah this guy is coming he's a
showman oh dude he's coming in hot
i wanted to do like an obviously junk
award but everybody went dude
that guy's on [ __ ] that guy's on
pluto he's smoking moon rocks that guy
i'll tell you what he was selling the
sizzle though that guy moves merchandise
dude i would move into that guy's house
all right uh great job great job so far
two more honorable mentions
all right great this is [ __ ]
fantastic thank you so much everybody
this is we appreciate it so much [ __ ]
fun
a little frightened but we appreciate
yeah some of you guys so i call it
garbage fabulous
as you can see i put a uh patio door
okay inside i got a magnetic screen for
my dog
it's in like a got a chest closet got
the
energy for the record this is like a
shipping container
jesus guys this guy's got a shipping
container on his property
wow wow which is pretty cool that's
garbage you can see i put a uh
patio door in the side i got a magnetic
screen magnetic
the magnetic is nice got a chest freezer
got the
energy drink uh fridge wow
with uh bourbon that's nice mixers
and beer that ain't bad that's pretty
[ __ ] good dude
holy [ __ ] if this if that fridge i'm
just letting you know if that that was
in a garage
and had food in it would have won oh
that's easy
yeah dude that oh you're getting a red
bull fish you've got a red bull fridge
and a shipping container on your
property
my cousin used to have an r2d2 one
okay play the tape trying to have a
turnover
great story trying to have a good time
talk to you guys
hey my uncle used to have a pair of
shoes run the tape
[Laughter]
guys holy [ __ ] more star trek guys huh
all right fair enough
all right last honorable mention all
right this is [ __ ] and we're gonna
come right in on the [ __ ] bullet too
right on the number i love it
all right in my fancy garbage i made my
garage
that's [ __ ] wow wow thank you all
right pause it wait wait
this is an honorable mention oh he's got
the [ __ ] tv
pause it this dude hit a [ __ ] home
run daddy dude first of all you know
what the classiest
i'm crash i get it why that floor is
nice that's like a pep boy dude that's
the classiest thing you can do with the
floor
is do the speckled the gray or the black
floor with the with the specks in it
oh my god dude that's commercial i like
how he has the craftsman theme
too the the the red the black and the
silver it's the huskers
the cornhole you got a huge corn hustle
all right
i thought i saw go back i thought i saw
a [ __ ] started from the beginning
he's got a huge
i saw that but i also thought i saw it
like uh the rack
yeah that thing right there in the
corner i mean i think it's just red
he's got a huge mural a
he's got a huge mural on the [ __ ]
floor a big [ __ ] cornhusker nebraska
guy he's got one on the wall he's got
trim
the walls are white red and black this
dude also he's got the tennis ball on
the string you see that that's nice so
when you pull the car
in you know when to stop wow this is for
the broads
this is a [ __ ] home run all right let
it run let it run
let's check out the fridge the garage
fridge in a great location too right at
the bottom of the steps
you dip back the flat screen on top of
the teeth
that's pretty classy
all right hit that pause oh wait open
that back up and hit pause please
dude he's got he's got a box of twisted
tee that's
nice wow but oh with a spout on it yeah
wow he's got some goose island he's got
some white claws he's got i don't know
what the yellow thing is but it's pretty
good he's got a solo sun
kiss down there too that's nice he's got
mango readers
he's got he's got damn dude that's got
red bulls on the
red bulls in the fridge and i see one
two liter
of minute made lemonade could be minute
may light
very very classy and a [ __ ] box of
pizzas a box of zago
can you zoom in on that so i can get a
brand on that pizza that looks
that's damn
oh it looks local yeah all right fully
the food detective this is
suicide foley lock the doors no one
leaves it could be popular
it could be papa john's ah papa john's
you're gonna lose a couple of points
there okay
whatever that's [ __ ] that solo sun
kiss looks good
hey that's freezing got the more he got
like the [ __ ] margarita
look at you got the shitty vodka on the
on the shelf there
nice great dude great [ __ ] job wow
that's clean living going into the
freezer oh
pause it pause it that's what a [ __ ]
freezer should look like
all meat yeah yeah yeah maybe a couple
of pop twin pops that's pretty good he's
got some
that's [ __ ] home run dude that's a
[ __ ] homer that is a nice
someone deserves a sticker this guy does
definitely something this guy didn't win
no this is the last honorable mention
wow
man that's [ __ ] great great job
wow it's good great [ __ ] job
you guys want to get into the clean
living award that was the end of the
video
we might have to give that guy a t-shirt
anyway hold on there's two more so
there's the winner and then there's the
clean living awards yeah so we have
two more garbagio award that's all all
the marbles
and then uh so someone sent him one just
too too clean not to put in all right
let's hit the clean living award let's
see that one
what's up boys uh we saw this guy in my
office yes we got
a drink on the tv look at the little bar
yeah
here's the fridge cocktails to shake
wow we got some pork wine some cabernet
my family still owns a vineyard in italy
so that's the rizzy wine
wow got some mixers look at ready to go
look at that in the container we're
ready to go the pellegrinos
not too shady not too shabby at all my
damn dude that's it that's a [ __ ] wow
height operation you got going that's
nice wow
okay i get that team award who gets the
t-shirts
just the winner just the winner yeah
anyone else you guys listen it's it's
your show
we might throw him a shirt we might
throw him a shirt we'll thank him him
and the husker him and the husker
that's the clue we've been giving out
all the shirts someone just said phil
who doesn't want to go back to nobu
you're giving out merchants
oh god all right um what else
all right this so this is the winner
right here whoa whoa yeah this next this
next button
i press is okay hang on the marbles
so this is the winner coming up winner
all right now we want to thank everybody
for submitting
okay uh great job [ __ ] fantastic
response
that one couple you got to get into a
30-day program
okay outpatient improvement you're going
to be separated for a little while
that's where it's tough when the both of
your addicts and you both got to go in
you can't go to the same joint you'll be
a better person on the other end of it
though
yeah but great [ __ ] job
wow yeah thank you for everyone who
submitted also this i had so much fun
going through these
um if you didn't make the cut it's we're
gonna have plenty more of these type of
things
and thank you to you dylan for all the
hard work oh yeah so it looks great guys
let me know when you're ready
okay here we go this is the winner of
the ru garbage
2020 garage fridge contest
end of summer at first inaugural
inaugural first annual annual
all right here we go
drumroll
here's my garage fridge
industrial industrial victory unit
what that used to belong to a restaurant
i worked at 15 years ago
that has since gone out of business and
then i bought at the bank auction
when they were cleaning the place out
pause it pause it
dude going dude getting an industrial
fridge at a bank auction at a place used
to work with is some [ __ ] clean
living
holy [ __ ] this guy ain't [ __ ] this
guy's playing [ __ ] chess not
checkers all right let's see
cleaning the place out still got the
stuff on the door for where they would
keep the meat that's great ribeye kc
strips
and inside we've got all the things that
are good
a couple ipas a little party liquor some
seltzers
busch light which is pretty much water
in iowa
nobody thought to [ __ ] put a little
water on a mug and throw it in the
freezer you [ __ ] animals
wow [ __ ] chilled glasses out there in
iowa
holy [ __ ] keep it going
wisconsin and then on the bottom
what i've got a keg set up with two
faucets i've got
homemade beer in the back keg and then
ultra in the front one
and then i just keep the tubes inside
because i didn't want to cut a hole in
the side of the fridge it works pretty
good this way
yeah because you're a [ __ ] gentleman
oh [ __ ] so there you are boys
is that trash or what that's [ __ ]
crap top of the heat
patio cow damn yeah winner chicken
dinner
winner winner shout out to jeff l yes
you're awesome
please yeah i'll email might have it in
my holy [ __ ] dude that's
i mean dude to keep like the [ __ ] you
can't say it was rigged
no i i didn't even listen i've been
garbage my whole [ __ ] life i never
thought industrial fridge no i showed
you what i family's working with
that's something else dude holy [ __ ]
dude he's got the keg he's got tubes
he's got valves and [ __ ]
and homemade beer and did you notice
that what he called party liquor
parties
[Laughter]
is off to you and your family sir you
come from good stock i don't know what
you do for a living but you got a little
cage
she had about two tree green in that
fridge
[Laughter]
damn dude that was [ __ ] awesome
congratulations man i'll reach out to
you
that was something [ __ ] else wow
i was [ __ ] blown i was not didn't
even not even register
and i didn't even think of the [ __ ]
frosted glasses no not once in my life
i've ever thought to do that which for a
while we had them in our in our regular
refrigerator
foley was scared for a second i didn't
save a good one for last i could see it
no
i didn't know you did a great job buddy
that was fantastic amazing
thank you everybody we appreciate it so
much shout out to jeff for winning guys
this was such a fun [ __ ] episode i
appreciate it what a great episode
um as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes
full video is available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well we really
[ __ ] appreciate those numbers are
going up every [ __ ] week we love all
the support uh also
shout out to the people running the
facebook pages and the reddit page yes
thank you guys
now can we get in on that or is that
lame i'm in on it somebody invited me in
on i'll invite you somebody invited me
all right yeah get in there and mix it
up yeah mix it up with the gang thank
you so much guys and
uh as always uh for all of uh the
the first fifth the most recent 15
episodes are available
on youtube on itunes wherever you get
your podcast
but if you want the whole catalog and
the catalog of every show on gas digital
like 10 years of [ __ ] legion of
skanks you can go to guest digital
gasdigital.com use promo code ayg
you get to save a couple of bucks we get
to make a couple of bucks makes the
world go around you know what i mean we
appreciate it so much
we get the wet our beak and so many of
you guys have [ __ ] done that already
we get the the numbers at the end of the
month that's fantastic yeah
we really appreciate it and also i don't
know if you guys got your emails but the
t-shirts have been shipped
yeah yeah so you should be going out you
should have them soon and we're gonna be
doing uh another pre-sale
in a little bit here and um hopefully
have some new merch and all that kind of
stuff for you guys also you want to hear
how much i care about the fans i don't
think i told you this
tell me they don't ship to canada for
some reason so i was placing orders for
people in canada i'm going to get them
and then piggyback them to canada
that's how we do it over here at ayg
we're a [ __ ] family
what'd i tell you folks when you're
reaching for a best pal
you're [ __ ] making a kippy even if
you are canadian
yeah gang we love you we'll see you next
week